- When I first started
climbing, I was so bad.
I was so terrible, so slow.
I'd tear my skin up all the time.
And I was like, how the heck are we going
to go and do Mount Kilimanjaro?
Three words: I don't know.
Those three words, three of the most
important words in my life.
All discoveries happen from I don't know.
(piano music)
My name is Kyle Maynard, and
I have an extremely hard time
saying what it is exactly that I do.
I've been an athlete my entire life.
Football, to wrestling, to
weight-lifting, and Brazilian
jiu jitsu, and now, most
recently, taking on climbing
some of the highest
mountains in the world.
I was born with congenital
amputation, so basically it
means my arms end at the elbows,
my legs end at the knees.
You know, I think some people,
they look at me and maybe
even feel sorry for me, but
really, truthfully, my life
doesn't look a whole lot
different than yours.
You know, I type on the
computer the same way,
You know, I use my phone, just like anybody else.
I'm on Bumble like anybody,
any other single person my age.
My first experience with
climbing really anything
of significance was in a
CrossFit competition in 2010.
The first workout was you had
to do a thousand meter row
on this rowing machine and
a sprint up Stone Mountain.
Everybody else did it in maybe 25 minutes.
It took me an hour and 46 minutes.
I tore all the skin up on my
arms, but I got to the top,
and I was like, “Wow, this
is breathtakingly beautiful.”
And I told my friend that night, I said,
“I want to climb Mount Kilimanjaro.”
I don't know if I can;
I don't know if I can't,
but I do know that I want
to try to figure it out.
I want to go and find
a way and get up there.
There were a ton of challenges
with getting into climbing,
and the biggest one was the gear.
I literally started with
bath towels duct taped
to my arms and my feet.
'Cause I couldn't go to the store and buy
a typical pair of shoes,
so we had to come up
with a unique solution.
Now to climb, I use a carbon
fiber special custom shoe.
I used those to bear crawl up Kilimanjaro.
(cheers)
Then, me and my team, we took
on climbing Mount Aconcagua,
the highest peak in South America.
I felt my body was in full shut-down mode.
Man, it was brutal at moments,
but it was breathtakingly beautiful.
At that top of the mountain, you know,
you can almost make out
and see the curvature of the earth.
I mean, it was just a
moment I'll never forget.
(cheers)
The reasons I climb aren't that
different from other people.
95% of it does suck.
I'm staring at the dirt.
I'm not even able to go
and talk to my friends
and see the beautiful views unless I stop
and sit down and look,
but that five percent
that doesn't suck, it's amazing.
Getting to a place that
there's no way my wheelchair
could have brought me
there, that's what I love.
I'm not trying to live to be a thousand.
Like, I want to go out there and
have my life mean something.
When I've gotten down and
I've looked at the mountain,
and I see what we've
achieved, it's like: “Wow!”
Maybe that was a really bad
idea that we were there,
but it was beautiful.